Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir sagen heute Olalala Liga und blicken nach Spanien, fragen uns, was ist denn da so los? Und das wollen wir besprechen mit Ben Barthmann, freien Journalisten unter anderem fürs Box unterwegs. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Ben, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt.
Hi Max, freut mich mal wieder hier zu sein.
Das mich umso mehr, Ben. Du bist so ein bisschen meine Go-To-Station, wenn es um die spanische Liga geht. Deswegen dürften sich dich auch schon so manche Hörerinnen und Hörer kennen aus der letzten Saison. Jetzt sind vier Spieltage gespielt in der spanischen Liga. Da wird es höchste Zeit, dass wir mal wieder miteinander sprechen und mal drauf gucken, was so los ist. Und völlig überraschend würde ich mal mit den großen Vereinen beginnen wollen. Aber ich hoffe, wir haben auch noch Zeit für ein paar kleinere. Kannst du mir mal sagen, der FC Barcelona, das sieht für mich ganz hervorragend aus. Vier Siege, kein Unentschieden, keine Niederlage, 14 zu drei Tore, drohen und führen die Liga mal wieder an. Ist die Dominanz, die ich da in den Zahlen sehe, denn auch auf dem Platz schon zu sehen, läuft es wieder bei Barca?
Was heißt wieder?
Immer noch, ja.
Immer noch, ja. Das trifft vielleicht eher. Ich würde grundsätzlich schon sagen, ich finde sie diese Saison eigentlich sehr spannend. Gerade weil sich am Kader dann doch einiges geändert hat, ohne dass so viel über den Haufen geworfen wurde, was in der letzten Saison auch schon gut funktioniert hat. Also praktisch nehmen wir die letzte Saison plus jetzt noch mal an der einen oder anderen Stellschraube gedreht und ein bisschen was gemacht. Und schon sieht das alles noch mal ein kleines Stückchen besser aus, finde ich.
Wer sind da für dich so die entscheidenden Neuzugänge, die du spannend findest?
Naja, also jetzt müsste man natürlich zuerst noch über Vidal reden. Ich glaube aber, dass der gar nicht so wichtig ist. Also, ist so ein bisschen ein Rollenspieler, glaube ich. So ein bisschen die Alternative zu Paulinho, der jetzt zurück nach China gewechselt ist.
Hat der schon mal gespielt, Vidal? Also kriegt der Einsatzzeiten?
Der hat schon mal gespielt, ja. Wenn er kommt, dann ist es meistens auch sehr deutlich, dass er ein Rollenspieler ist. Dann wird das System ein bisschen angepasst. Er ist mehr so der, der dann noch mithilft, das Ergebnis zu sichern, vielleicht ein bisschen physisch mit reinbringt ins Spiel. Das ist nicht so ganz Barca-typisch, aber hat sich in der letzten Saison durchaus hier und da mal bewährt. Da haben sie, glaube ich, einen ganz guten Transfer gemacht, zumal Paulinho für eine satte Summe zurückgewechselt ist oder wechseln wird. Ich meine, dass er jetzt noch ausgeliehen ist und dann später verkauft wird. Aber wenn du nach den wichtigen Transfers fragst, dann ist das für mich einmal –das ist die Frage, wie man ausspricht, ist der Brasilianer Malcolm.
Hätte ich jetzt auch gesagt.
Vermutlich, man weiß es nicht.
Rechtsaußen von Bordeaux.
Genau, rechtsaußen. Bei Barca wahrscheinlich auch mal linksaußen. So ein bisschen der offensive Wechselspieler für Dembélé, für sicherlich auch irgendwann mal Messi, falls es da was sein sollte. Da haben sie auf jeden Fall gut nachgebessert, mit 21 Jahren und auch wirklich entwicklungsfähig. Und im Mittelfeld dann Artur, auch aus Brasilien, der ist allerdings direkt aus Brasilien gekommen, von Grêmio. Der soll tatsächlich sehr ähnlich zu Xavi sein in seiner Spielanlage. Bis jetzt hat man noch nicht ganz so viel gesehen. Also er wurde zum Beispiel jetzt auch einmal nicht in den Kader genommen für das Spiel gegen Real Sociedad, soweit ich mich erinnere. Aber auch ein Versprechen für die Zukunft auf jeden Fall, der jetzt schon eine relativ wichtige Rolle in der Saison einnehmen könnte. Also die beiden würde ich so als Hauptverpflichtungen betiteln.
Ganz interessant. Und wie lief jetzt die Saison bisher für Barca?
Ja gut, hast du ja schon festgestellt. Also viel Siege in vier Spielen, super viele Tore geschossen. Ich glaube auch erst zwei oder drei sind es glaube ich kassiert. Also sowohl offensiv gefährlich als auch defensiv stabil. Was jetzt aber auch wie gesagt nicht die große Überraschung sein sollte, ist ein eingespieltes Team, das letzte Saison schon ganz viel richtig gemacht hat. Du hast vorne immer noch Messi drin, jetzt hast du auch noch Dembélé, der wirklich momentan in sehr, sehr guter Verfassung ist. Also das sieht top aus. Das ist halt die Frage, wie sich das dann über die ganze Saison lang streckt, ob sie dieses Niveau aufrechterhalten können und ob es dann auch in den wirklichen Top-Duellen so funktioniert. Weil bis jetzt war es ja dann schon herausfordernd, aber so richtig die großen Gegner waren es ja eigentlich nicht.
Ja, die berühmte Aussagekraft der Tabelle nach vier Spieltagen, das haben wir natürlich nicht nur, wenn wir auf die Bundesliga und die Premier League gucken, sondern auch hier bei der spanischen Liga in der Champions League auch 4-0 gegen den PSV Eindhoven gestartet. Das sah alles sehr gut aus. Hat sich denn was im Spiel von Barca verändert oder ist das das, woran man sich jetzt schon sehr gut gewohnt hat, nur halt ohne so manchen bekannten Namen aus der Vergangenheit?
Also es ist schon ein bisschen verändert, würde ich sagen. Allerdings eher auf eine lange Sicht gesehen, jetzt nicht von der letzten zu dieser Saison. Das, glaube ich, wäre ein bisschen zu viel gesagt. Sie haben in den letzten Jahren so eine leichte Entwicklung dazu gemacht, dass es nicht mehr dieser ganz krasse Stil ist mit Ballbesitz und wir spielen dann gegenpressig, wenn wir den Ball verloren haben. Aber die Entwicklung ist ja wirklich alles andere als neu. Eigentlich ist es ein bisschen direkter hier und da, ein bisschen physischer hier und da. Auch mal gerne ein bisschen mit der Brechstange, aber alles immer noch sehr Barca-like. Also irgendeine Diskussion um den Spielstil sollte in nächster Zeit dann nicht auftreten. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, zumal sie ja immer noch erfolgreich damit sind und ich glaube, sich einfach ein bisschen angepasst hat man das, was halt so der Fußball jetzt aktuell auch erfordert in Sachen Umschaltspiel beispielsweise.
Letzte Saison mit 14 Punkten Vorsprung vor Atletico meister geworden. Wie wichtig ist die Champions League für Barca? Wir kennen das ja hier vom FC Bayern in Deutschland, dass selbst wenn man die Liga dominiert oder gerade weil man sie dann dominiert, der Blick eher aufs internationale Abschneiden geht. Und da haben wir ja Barca jetzt schon häufiger nicht mehr gesehen in den Runden der letzten Mannschaften.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich richtig, dass Barca diese Saison, glaube ich, einen sehr großen Fokus auf die Champions League legt. Das liegt nicht nur daran, dass Messi in seiner Kapitänsrede im Stadion vor der Saison das Ziel ausgegeben hat, mit relativ deutlichen Worten.
Es gibt eine Kapitänsrede im Stadion vor der Saison?
Ja, das ist so ein typisches Barca-Ding eigentlich, das ist ganz oft, das heißt ganz oft, an bestimmten Zeitpunkten in der Saison können Fans ins Stadion kommen, für wenig bis gar kein Geld, sich da reinsetzen, kriegen das Team präsentiert, können sich Reden anhören, Neuzugänge werden vorgestellt, Trainer spricht ein paar Worte, der Kapitän spricht ein paar Worte und nachdem Iniesta jetzt nach Japan gewechselt ist, hatte eben Messi zum ersten Mal das Mikro in der Hand.
Macht er sowas frei oder vom Zettel?
Das hat er frei gemacht, hat er später gesagt. Er hat sich so leicht vorbereitet, aber letztendlich die Rede frei gehalten. Man hat ihm aber schon ein bisschen angesehen, dass es nicht so ganz seine Art ist, sich da hinzustellen, um im Mikro irgendwo rein zu brechen. Aber er hat am Ende das klare Ziel formuliert, Champions League gewinnen möchte er in diesem Jahr. Dementsprechend ist der Wille da auf jeden Fall da, gerade nach den letzten Jahren, genau wie du es gesagt hast, das ist halt nicht der Anspruch von Barca gewesen, nach den letzten Erfolgen, die sie eben gefeiert hatten. Dass sie da zum Teil ja auch wirklich, wenn man jetzt gerade mal das letzte Jahr guckt, schon blamabel ausgeschieden sind, mit so einer großen Führung noch aus der Hand gegeben. Da ist Nachholbedarf schon vorhanden.
Genau, also das war 3-0 im Hinspiel und dann Rückspiel gegen den AS Rom verloren. Das war ja das in der letzten Saison für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das nicht mehr genau vor Augen haben, wie das war. Dann lass uns mal über Real Madrid sprechen. Die haben einen prominenten Abgang zu verzeichnen. Cristiano Ronaldo werden vielleicht viele gar nicht mitbekommen haben. Spielt jetzt bei Juve, das ist so ein aufsteigender kleiner Verein aus Italien. Ist denn die Sieben wieder besetzt worden? Beziehungsweise ist es eine rhetorische Frage. Ich weiß es schon, warum wurde denn die Sieben noch mal nachbesetzt? Das hat mich total gewundert, dass man die nicht erst mal offen lässt. Das ist ja auch für den nachfolgenden Spieler gar nicht so einfach.
Meinst du die Rückennummer?
Die Rückennummer Sieben, ja.
Die Rückennummer Sieben, ja. Ich schätze mal, so wie Ronaldo sich verzogen hat, hatte man dann vielleicht auch nicht so Lust, einfach eine Rückennummer im ganz klassischen Sinne frei zu halten. Und hatte sich dann halt gedacht, gut, die Sieben, werden wir schon Mariano Dias zurückholen, der ja auch eine Stange Geld gekostet hat, warum nicht?
Okay, er trägt jetzt dann die große Bürde dieser Rückennummer. Was hat denn das für ein Echo hinterlassen bei Real, dieser Abgang von Cristiano Ronaldo? Denn wir haben damals auch hier im Rasenfunk viel über Juve gesprochen und wie das zustande kam, wie man das finanzieren kann, ob das alles Sinn ergibt. Und meinem Eindruck nach wurde aber eigentlich relativ wenig darüber gesprochen, was das eigentlich mit Real Madrid macht.
Ja, ich hatte auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass das eigentlich die Taktik von Real war, möglichst wenig darüber zu sprechen, dass Ronaldo weg ist.
Und so was funktioniert?
Ja, also klar wird da mal nachgefragt, das ist ja logisch. Und so ein bisschen allgegenwärtlich ist das auch. Es ist immer die erste Saison ohne Ronaldo, das erste Spiel ohne Ronaldo, das erste Champions League-Spiel ohne Ronaldo. Und da wird sicherlich auch noch das eine und andere kommen. Jetzt haben sie aber das Glück gehabt, dass sie ja wirklich sehr gut in die Saison gestartet sind, mit drei Siegen am Stück. Also gab es erst mal wenig anderes zu Kritik, zumal sie ja 4-1, 4-1, 3-0 gewonnen haben, also wenig zu meckern. Da hat sich dann irgendwie so ein bisschen verflüssigt das Thema. Jetzt hast du dann halt vorne ein bisschen Probleme hier und da, meiner Meinung nach, dass es nicht ganz perfekt besetzt ist. Also ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass ein Offensivspieler in weiterer Ehe schon gut getan hätte. Und dass so Gerüchte mit Hazard oder so gut, weiß man jetzt nicht, ob wirklich was dran war, aber gewünscht hätten sie sich sowas bestimmt. Jetzt halt Isco, Wenzema, Bale plus Diaz, eventuell Asensio ist natürlich auch alles andere als verkehrt. Aber auch gerade vom Namen her, der ja bei Real schon immer irgendwo eine gewisse Wichtigkeit hat, was man da auf den Platz stellt, sind sie wahrscheinlich nicht ganz zufrieden mit dem Sommer, den sie da abgeliefert haben.
Ja, trotz eben des guten Startes. Also du hast es schon angesprochen, haben auch 10 Punkte, noch keine Niederlage, 11 zu 3 Tore. Täuschter Eindruck, dass Bale unumstrittener denn je ist bei Real. Das ist jetzt nur mal eine distanzierte Wahrnehmung. Aber der spielt da jetzt immer?
Der spielt immer, ja. Aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass er unumstrittener als sonst ist. Er hat ja in der letzten Saison im Champions-League-Finale eigentlich mehr oder weniger die Partie entschieden mit seinen beiden. Seinen beiden Treffern. Als er von der Bank kam, also unumstritten. Es ist auf jeden Fall aus dem Schatten so ein bisschen getreten von Ronaldo. Es war klar, wenn der weg ist, muss jemand anderes das ausfüllen. Und nicht nur durch seine Tore im Champions-League-Finale, sondern auch allgemein, wer jetzt eben spielt, der hat ja auch in der Champions League wieder getroffen. Hat er sich halt jetzt so ein bisschen ins Schaufenster gestellt oder ist im Schaufenster nach ganz vorne, ganz vorne gelatscht und hat sich dahingestellt?
Und vor allem vorne rechts hat er sich hingestellt. Also spielt Inverted Winger, also so wie Arjen Robben, der dann immer nach innen zieht, das spielt jetzt Gareth Bay bei Real.
Ja, das ist ja mit seiner Torgefahr und allgemein seinem Tempo und so weiter schon auch irgendwo naheliegend, dass er das darf und auch kann. Also ich meine, das ist ja auch nicht ganz neu, meine ich jetzt.
Ist klar, mir ist einfach nur aufgefallen, dass er jetzt immer in der Startelf stand und immer vorne rechts. Das fand ich eben ganz interessant, weil er eben unter anderem im Champions League Finale von der Bank kam und es gab da ja auch durchaus immer wieder Gerüchte, ob er vielleicht da über einen Vereinswechsel nachdenken würde. Was hat sich denn…
Ja, die hat er, glaube ich, auch mal mehr oder weniger deutlich rausgesprochen. Aber er hat ja kürzlich in einem Interview mit der Daily Mail so ein bisschen mysteriös gesagt, über wer jetzt besser ist, Zidane oder Lopetegui als neuer Trainer, möchte er nicht zu viel sagen. Kann auch gut sein, dass er da ein bisschen darauf hindeuten wollte, dass er sich mit Zidane vielleicht nicht ganz so gut verstanden hat, wie er selbst mit Lopetegui.
Was ja schon so mit das spannendste nächste Thema ist bei Real. Also wir erinnern uns alle, Lopetegui, ganz kurz vor der Weltmeisterschaft wurde er vom spanischen Nationaltraineramt entbunden, weil er sich eben schon mit Real Madrid einig war, dort zu übernehmen und das auch seinem Verbandspräsidenten wohl sehr spät mitgeteilt hat. Jetzt haben wir damals viel darüber diskutiert, was macht das mit der spanischen Nationalmannschaft. Und eigentlich so nur alle Experten waren sich einig, was für einen tollen Fußball Lopetegui vor allem hat spielen lassen. Und vor allem deswegen hat man darüber ja auch so besonders diskutiert. Lässt sich denn davon schon ein bisschen etwas bei Real erkennen? Oder ist es noch zu früh, um irgendwelche Veränderungen bei Madrid auszumachen, taktischer Art oder spielerischer Art?
Auf gar keinen Fall zu früh. Also ich finde, dass Real aktuell einen sehr schönen Fußball spielt, einen guten Beibesitz. Das war ja von Lopetegui auch zu erwarten. Höheres Bessing, das kennt man ja sowohl von der spanischen Nationalmannschaft, als auch vom FC Porto damals. Da ist auf jeden Fall schon großer Fortschritt zu erkennen. Und gerade mit den Spielern, die er natürlich hat, glaube ich auch nicht so unerwartet, dass das alles relativ schnell klappt. Ich meine Modric groß, Casemiro ist ein tolles Mittelfeld, dann Isco als Bindeglied nach vorne mit dazu, Benzema ein toller Spieler, ein Beibesitz, der sehr spielintelligent ist. Und dann hast du halt mit Bale noch so einen richtigen Superstar vorne drin. Also ich meine, mit der Qualität, bloß ein super Trainer, der das im letzten Jahr noch schon gezeigt hat, war ja relativ klar, dass die gut funktionieren und da erst mal ihre Punkte holen. Hatten jetzt auch noch nicht die ganz großen Herausforderungen in der Liga. Wie gesagt, schon wieder die Aussagekraft nach vier Spieltagen. Aber jetzt sowohl gegen Rom als auch in der Liga sah das alles ganz gut aus. Also ich denke, da ist noch ein bisschen was mehr zu erwarten, aber es sieht schon jetzt sehr, sehr ordentlich aus.
Und was glaubst du ist so die Erwartungshaltung? Also klar, Real Madrid will ja immer alles gewinnen und Real Madrid ist ja in der Regel auch in der Lage, immer alles zu gewinnen. Gleichzeitig kannst du das ja nicht wegdiskutieren, dass mit Cristiano Ronaldo der Zielspieler gegangen ist, der sämtliche Torekorde vor allem in der Champions League pulverisiert hat. Hat das ein bisschen den Erwartungsdruck jetzt auch von Lopetegui genommen oder müssen es eigentlich doch wieder alle Titel sein? Sonst passt das einfach nicht so real.
Also man hat auf der einen Seite, glaube ich, den Vorteil, wenn Ronaldo weg ist, dann muss der Rest der Mannschaft irgendwie einen Schritt nach vorne machen, muss sich präsentieren, muss Verantwortung übernehmen, kann sich vielleicht auch insgesamt ein bisschen freier einfach bewegen, weil nicht mehr alles so zugeschnitten ist auf einen Spieler. Gleichzeitig fehlt natürlich eine brutale Qualität. Das ist sowohl im Abschluss als auch einfach, dass man sagt, da vorne steht noch Ronaldo, wir können als Gegner gar nicht so viele Spieler nach vorne schicken, beispielsweise, wenn man das jetzt ein mutiger spielt, gut gegen den Champions League zum Beispiel, da fehlt so ein gewisser Angstfaktor, der Gegner glaube ich auch einfach. Also, das ist schon ein großer Verlust. Trotzdem ist die Zielsetzung bei Real Madrid eigentlich immer alles gewinnen, genau wie du gesagt hast. Und daran werden sie sich am Ende auch messen lassen müssen. Gerade um da nicht den Eindruck aufkommen zu lassen, ohne Ronaldo wäre das in den letzten Jahren auch alles nix geworden.
Ja, gut. Also ich hatte jetzt auch nicht damit gerechnet, dass du mir sagst, es gibt ganz niedrige Erwartungen. Wie sind denn die Erwartungen bei Atletico Madrid? Wenn ich mir angucke, die haben im Supercup noch nach Verlängerung gegen Real gewonnen, aber dann Unentschieden gegen Valencia, Sieg gegen Valé Cano, dann gegen Celta Vigo verloren und gegen Eibar wieder nur ein Unentschieden. Das heißt, man steht aktuell auf Tabellenplatz 9 mit nur 5 Punkten, was ja das Wichtigere ist als der Tabellenplatz. Läuft da irgendwas quer bei Atletico? Was fehlt?
Was fehlt, ist eine gute Frage. Jetzt haben sie in der Champions League immerhin 2-1 gegen Monaco gewonnen. Also ganz katastrophal kann es nicht sein. Man muss auch dazu sagen, dass wenn man gegen Valencia spielt, ist schwierig. Wenn man gegen Celta Vigo verliert, das ist so ein ganz klassischer Favoritenschreck, die in der Liga mit ihrem Konterfußball regelmäßig mal jemanden von den großen drei ärgern und Eibar darf man jetzt auch nicht vergessen. Ich sehe gerade eine Tabelle, die haben auch nicht so gut gespielt, so wie letzte Saison. Aber wenn man daran zurückdenkt, dann fällt einem ja ein. Wir haben auch damals darüber gesprochen, dass die statistisch überall vorne mit dabei waren. Also die haben auch einen guten Fußball gespielt in der letzten Saison. Dementsprechend würde ich jetzt da nicht auf den Panikknopf hauen, was Atletico angeht. Zumal die ja, gerade wenn wir jetzt über einen Anspruch reden, so ein bisschen unter dem Dortmund so droben leiden, nämlich einen Superkader haben im Regelfall. Auch deutlich besser als der Rest der Liga. Und dann sich hinstellen und sagen, gut, eigentlich reicht ja auch die Qualifikation zur Champions League. Ist ja auch in Ordnung für uns. Das ist ja so ein bisschen bei Atletico einfach seit Jahren immer das gleiche. Die hauen da 70 Millionen für Thomas Lemar hin und am Ende sind keiner böse, wenn sie Dritter werden. Weil du halt einfach an Barca und Real, wird sich keiner beschweren, wenn sie da nicht dran vorbeikommen.
Und da sind es eben jetzt schon wieder fünf und sieben Punkte. Also da war der Saisonstart nicht so gut. Hat sich denn bei Atletico Madrid jetzt jenseits von den Ergebnissen, die ja auch eine Momentaufnahme sein können, hat sich sonst noch irgendetwas verändert oder ist das das Atletico, was wir jetzt im Grunde gefühlt schon seit vier, fünf Jahren kennen? Nämlich einfach seitdem da Diego Simeone das Steuer in der Hand hat.
Also ein Großteil ist natürlich gleich geblieben. Sie haben immer noch dieses Fivier 2. Sie können immer noch supergut verteidigen. Sie haben immer noch ihre Phasen, in denen sie mal tiefer stehen, mal höher angreifen. Das kennt man ja alles. Jetzt hat Simeone im letzten Jahr mal ein bisschen versucht, sein Team konstruktiver spielen zu lassen. Also ein bisschen mehr Beibesitz, ein bisschen mehr Spielaufbau. Hat dann ein paar Experimente gemacht, was dann meiner Meinung nach zulasten der defensiven Absicherung ging. Also da hatten sie meine Phasen, in der sie ordentlich geschlingert sind. Das muss aber eigentlich irgendwann mal passieren, weil immer nur das Gleiche machen, immer mit den gleichen Spielern oder wenig Veränderungen insgesamt an der ersten Elf, sage ich mal, ist halt auch schwierig. Man muss ja neue Reize setzen, ein bisschen was Neues reinbringen. Also er tüftelt auf jeden Fall hier und dort herum, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist die Strategie bei Atletico seit Jahren die gleiche. Daran wird sich jetzt auch dieses Jahr nichts groß ändern.
Gibt es noch irgendwelche Neuverpflichtungen, interessante Spiele, auf die man achten soll, außer jetzt eben Le Mar, den du schon angesprochen hast?
Ja, Rodri, auf jeden Fall im Mittelfeld, der kam von Villarreal. Ich glaube, für rund 20 Millionen waren es, bin ich mir gerade nicht ganz sicher. Aber er ist ein top defensiver Mittelfeldspieler, meiner Meinung nach. Habe ich mich ein bisschen geärgert, dass er nicht zu einem Verein gegangen ist, der mit mehr Ballbesitz spielt, vielleicht, weil er das bei Villarreal wirklich sehr, sehr gut gemacht hat.
Mensch, Dortmund hat doch Sechser gesucht, da hätten sie doch mal da sein können.
Das wäre was gewesen, vielleicht ein bisschen unerreichbar für Dortmund, aber mit 20 Millionen eigentlich auch nicht so teuer. Hätte man drüber nachdenken können.
Gut, weiß man nicht. Also auf Rodri achten wir auf jeden Fall in Zukunft mal.
Ja, sollte man. Also kann ich empfehlen, auf den zu achten. Ich glaube, dass der auch in der spanischen Nationalmannschaft sehr bald mehr Einsätze kriegt. Der hat jetzt debütiert im Frühjahr irgendwann mal. Der wird sicherlich dadurch, dass er jetzt bei Atletico spielt, noch zusätzlich Rückenwind kriegen, dass er da auch in die Mannschaft reinkommt.
Der berühmte Effekt, dass man dann so in die Nationalmannschaft kommt. Lass uns mal noch über Valencia sprechen, denn die fallen eher negativ auf. Wir haben vorhin über einen Unentschieden gegen Atletico gesprochen zum Saisonauftakt, aber danach eine Niederlage gegen Espanyol, zwei Unentschieden und jetzt auch zu Hause gegen Juve 0-2 verloren und das gegen ein Juve ohne Cristiano Ronaldo über 60 Minuten der Spielzeit. Das heißt, der Saisonstart hat in der Liga mit drei Unentschieden und einer Niederlage überhaupt nicht geklappt und der Champions League mit einem 0-2 gegen einen dezimierten Gegner jetzt auch nicht so wirklich. Du hast vorhin vom Panik-Button gesprochen. Sollen wir den hier drücken oder sagen wir hier auch, was ja völlig legitim wäre, naja, vierter Spieltag, hold your horses, wird schon alles.
Also ich bin grundsätzlich immer Gegner vom Panik-Button. Aber bei Valencia ist es schon ein bisschen komisch, finde ich. Zumal sich jetzt am Kader nicht so viel geändert hat. Also da war es nicht so, dass sie große Qualität verloren haben oder irgendwelche neuen Sachen anstellen. Sie haben Greddisch behalten können, der letzte Saison wirklich ein sehr wichtiger Teil der Mannschaft war. Sie haben mit Marcelinho immer noch den gleichen Trainer. Jetzt ist eigentlich noch Verstärkung dazu gekommen, wenn man sich mal so die Zugänge ansieht. Die haben Batlleiye geholt, Gamero spielt jetzt vorne drin. Sie konnten Condogbia halten. Also da ist schon Qualität hinzugekommen, beziehungsweise konnte gehalten werden, was so ein bisschen die Frage war nach der letzten guten Saison. Sie haben sich finanziell immer besser aufgestellt. Also da sind die Sorgen auch kleiner geworden. Es ist schon ein bisschen komisch jetzt nach dem Start. Es ist auch nicht so gelaufen, dass man jetzt sagt, da war alles schlecht. Aber du hast recht, genau wie du gesagt hast, gegen zehn Mann Juventus 60 Minuten lang, dass man da 2-0 verliert, ist gerade in Kombination mit den Ergebnissen aus der Liga mit einem eigentlich nicht so hammerharten Start, klar ein paar typische Stolpersteine im Spielplan gehabt, aber ich meine, das war jetzt nicht so, dass sie einen mega harten Start in die Saison hatten, ist schon ein bisschen besorgniserregend. Andererseits ist Marcelinho ein Trainer, der eine Mannschaft im Laufe der Zeit entwickelt. Und vielleicht ist er aktuell dabei, etwas umzustellen, etwas ein bisschen anders auszuprobieren. Wir hatten ja vorhin über Silvione gesprochen, der letzte Saison sich ein bisschen an Ballbesitz-Veränderungen versucht hat. Vielleicht macht Marcelinho gerade etwas Ähnliches und dann dementsprechend gibt es noch Probleme, sich darauf einzustellen. Das könnte sein und ich hoffe, so wie sie Fußball gespielt haben letzte Saison, dass sie das wieder hinkriegen, weil dann sind sie eine absolute Bereicherung für die Liga.
Also letzte Saison vierter geworden mit 12 Punkten Vorsprung auf die Europa League-Plätze. Deswegen spielen sie jetzt Champions League, deswegen durften sie gegen Juve ran, deswegen dürfen sie in der Champions League als nächstes bei Manchester United ran. Also auch eine sehr interessante Gruppe, dann auch noch mit den Young Boys Bern. Ich bin ja auch ein Freund derjenigen, die nicht gleich auf den Panik-Button drücken, deswegen rede ich auch so gerne mit dir. Ben, ist denn die Wahrnehmung in Spanien eine ähnliche?
Bezüglich Valencia? Also bei Spanien ist es ja leider immer so ein bisschen das Problem, dass die Medien immer gerne nach Fressen suchen, irgendwas, wo sie schön draufhauen können. Und sowas wie Valencia bietet sich dann natürlich, bietet sich an. Jetzt haben die aber das Glück, dass sie nicht zu den Top-3-Vereinen gehören, also das Ganze sich noch einigermaßen im Zaum hält, weil die meisten Leute einfach was über Real, Barca und Atletico lesen wollen. Aber klar, nach so einem Fehlstart. Und dann hast du noch Marcelinho, der nicht unbedingt der beliebteste Trainer in Spanien ist, der auch als ein bisschen ein Querdenker gilt, ein bisschen schwierig in der Handhabung für die Vereinsführung. Er ist auf jeden Fall wird beäugt, kritisch beäugt. Und wenn das so weitergeht, dann kann man da erwarten, dass es so einen leichten Trichter geben wird, aus dem Valencia sich vielleicht schwer tut, wieder rauszukommen.
Gut, behalten wir es einfach mal im Auge. Ich denke, wir werden über Valencia noch ein bisschen häufiger sprechen hier im Kurzpass. Wir wollen uns aber nicht nur die Negativgeschichten erzählen. Sag mir mal, welche Mannschaft hatte ich denn bisher nach vier Liga-Spieltagen überrascht? Gibt es irgendwelche Dinge, die die Hörerinnen und Hörer wissen sollten, die jetzt vielleicht sogar nicht mal die Tabelle vor Augen haben?
Also, dann sollten wir die Tabelle vielleicht kurz vor Augen führen, weil gerade wenn man sie sich anguckt, dann könnte man so ein bisschen von einem Zwergenaufstand sprechen. Auch wieder, klar, vier Spieltage, aber wir haben Hirona auf Platz 3, Alaves Platz 4, Celta Vigo Platz 5, Espanyol Platz 6, Retafel Platz 7. Und dann kommen irgendwann mal Bilbao, Atletico, wieder nichts wie Real, Sevilla und Valencia. Also, irgendwo ist zum Start der Saison schon was anders gelaufen, als es geplant war. Das kann man jetzt auf mehrere Schultern verteilen. Wir haben ja letztes Mal über Hirona gesprochen, zum Beispiel, die mit ihrer Manchester City-Kooperation zum Beispiel schon wieder ein paar Leihspieler bekommen haben. Wir haben Alaves, die sich da wunderbar oben drin halten, trotz sehr geringen Mitteln. Wir haben Retafel, die über den Platz rumpeln, wie die allerletzte Mannschaft uns alles kaputt treten, was ihnen über den Weg läuft, aber trotzdem zwei Siege geholt haben. Also, nicht hübsch, aber erfolgreich. Unter anderem gegen Sevilla gewonnen, dann Espanyol. Sehr ähnliche Mannschaft, die gehen sehr hart zu Werke. Die hauen auch mal dazwischen, sind auch mit zwei Siegen jetzt gestartet, einem Unentschieden an der Niederlage. Sie haben gegen Valencia gewonnen. Das sind so diese Mannschaften, die im Laufe der Saison als typische Stolpersteine gelten, habe ich ja vorhin auch schon mal kurz gesagt. Die sind super schwer zu bespielen, die scheißen sich gar nichts, wenn es mal ein bisschen härter wird. Die sind wirklich eklig, auch für die Top-Vereine zu bespielen. Das ist eigentlich ein schönes Zeichen für die Liga, finde ich. Dass es das ein bisschen differenziert, so was für Mannschaften da vorhanden sind. Und dass die sich auch wirklich zu wehr setzen und sich nicht irgendwie in einer defensiven 8-1-1-Formation verriegeln, sondern auch versuchen, z.B. hoch zu pressen, ein bisschen Druck auszuüben, dabei halt auch mal dann die Fouls ziehen müssen. Klar, aber sich schon auf jeden Fall wehrhaft zeigen. Das kann man vielleicht allgemein so ein bisschen sagen.
Ich glaube, da haben wir letztes Jahr schon drüber gesprochen. Da hatte ich rausgesucht, die durchschnittlichen gewonnenen Dribblings pro Liga. Und da hatte die Deutsche Bundesliga nur einen Verein, der mehr als zehn Dribblings pro Spiel gewonnen hatte, nämlich Leipzig. Und in der spanischen Liga waren es insgesamt zehn Mannschaften, die das hatten. Also da hat man allein an den Zahlen, das ist ja nicht immer so, aber allein an den Zahlen konnte man sehen, das ist eine andere Art Fußball, die da gespielt wird. Und das höre ich jetzt hier in deinen Worten auch so ein bisschen raus.
Ja, man kann es nicht pauschalisieren, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein leichter Trend zu erkennen. Und ein allgemeiner Unterschied besteht auf jeden Fall zur Bundesliga. Gut, aber jetzt wolltest du einen einzelnen Verein hören, oder?
Du, wenn wir es zeitlich schaffen, gerne auch noch zwei. Sag mir einfach, worauf soll ich achten, wenn ich demnächst mal die Chance habe, vielleicht mir ein paar spanische Spiele anzugucken? Oder wen sollte ich mal ein bisschen näher mir angucken, einfach weil es eine interessante Mannschaft ist? Aus welchen Gründen auch immer? Kann wegen mir auch die Stadion Wurscht sein?
Gut, die Stadion Wurscht kenne ich nicht, aber ich kann trotzdem Celta Vigo empfehlen. Das ist seit Jahren eigentlich immer so, dass man sagt, guck dir Celta Vigo an, haben eigentlich immer so einen Kader gehabt, bei dem man jetzt nicht auf ersten Anschlag alle Spieler kennt oder sagt, ah, okay, der und der hat mal hier und hier gespielt, sondern die hatten sich da mal was zusammengebastelt aus verschiedenen Nationen zusammen mit einem interessanten Trainer. Der Trainer hat jetzt diese Saison gewechselt, heißt jetzt Antonio Mohamed, kommt aus Argentinien und hat eine ganz große Aufgabe eigentlich zu bewältigen, gerade wenn man guckt, was für Spieler sie verloren haben. Also da waren schon Leistungsträger mit dabei, mit Castro zum Beispiel, war es, der zu Valencia gewechselt ist. Da haben sie an Qualität verloren und ich war jetzt eigentlich nicht so überzeugt davon, dass sie die gleiche Mannschaft sind, wie sie in den letzten Jahren waren. Nämlich wirklich eine Mannschaft, die super schnelle Angriffe spielt, die für jeden Gegner unbequem ist, die ganz regelmäßig auch gegen Barca zum Beispiel sehr, sehr gut ausgesehen hat, fand ich. Aber momentan kriegen sie das gut hin mit genau diesen schnellen Angriffen nach vorne, mit Aspas, Sisto zum Beispiel und der Stürmer vorne, wie heißt der? Gomes, Max Milano Gomes. Vielleicht der beste Mann, den sie im Kader haben.
Was nicht Emre Mohr? Ich dachte, Emre Mohr wäre natürlich der beste. Ich habe da nur so einen Instagram-Posting gesehen, da fühlte es sich so an, als wäre er der König.
Ich glaube, Emre Mohr ist eher momentan nicht so der König, sondern eher der, der auf der Bank links außen spielt.
Okay, der links draußen.
Nicht mal eingewechselt im letzten Spiel, ja. Er ist ja für 90 Minuten auf der Bank geblieben. Ja, super offensive, wie gesagt. Und dazu kommen jetzt noch, es war nicht immer so. Ihr Top-Ding, hatte ich das Gefühl, sehr, sehr gute Standards. Also da haben sie auf jeden Fall viel Arbeit gemacht. Es kann sein, dass es der Einfluss vom neuen Trainer ist. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine Mannschaft, die Spaß macht. Das hat man jetzt auch gesehen gegen Chirona. 3-2 ging hin und her, da war einige Action drin. Das kann man, könnte ich dir nachlegen, falls du was angucken willst und nicht nur eine Stadionwurst essen.
Ja, das mit der Stadionwurst wird schwieriger als das Angucken.
Ich glaube, es wird in Spanien allgemein schwierig, eine Stadionwurst zu finden.
Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, ich war vor zwei Jahren mal im Camp Nou. Da gab es eine Wurst, aber ich war erschrocken über den Zustand und die Wartezeit. Generell war ich sehr überrascht über die Stadion. Aber gut, anderes Thema. Wenn wir über die spanische Liga sprechen, dann müssen wir auch noch ein Thema aufbringen, was auch hier in Deutschland für einige Resonanz gesorgt hat, nämlich die Pflichtspiele, die außerhalb Spaniens ausgetragen werden sollen, namentlich in den USA. Da konnte man dann lesen davon, dass sich spanische Fußballer dagegen wehren wollten. Letztlich wird es jetzt aber kommen. Kannst du uns noch mal kurz zusammenfassen, um was geht es jetzt da? Waren das zwei Liga-Spiele, die nicht in Spanien gespielt werden oder waren es mehr?
Es sollte ein Spiel pro Saison sein, sobald ich mich erinnere. Jetzt war in den letzten Tagen eigentlich die Tendenz zu erkennen, dass es das Spiel durch Girona gegen den FC Barcelona sein wird. Girona hatte da relativ schnell gesagt, ja klar machen wir. Die waren davon durchaus angetan.
Kann man sagen, warum kriegen die dafür noch mal? Weil die dann ein größeres Stadion haben, was sie füllen, und deswegen dann die Stadion- Annahmen für die höher werden? Oder kommt die noch mal eine extra Zahlung?
Wobei die Spieltagseinnahmen jetzt, glaube ich, am Ende nicht den Ausschlag geben. Da geht es natürlich auch um Marketing und Präsentieren im Ausland. Sicherlich auch für Girona jetzt ein bisschen, um das Erlebnis in den USA gespielt zu haben, da Aufmerksamkeit zu generieren. Dafür noch einen relativ kleinen Verein, der ja auch irgendwo aufstrebend ist, mit Geldgeber im Hintergrund und auch der City-Kooperation. Durchaus attraktiv eigentlich. Dementsprechend, glaube ich, hatten sie sich da sehr schnell darauf geeinigt, dass das für sie als Verein in Ordnung wäre. Für Barca als Verein war es auch in Ordnung. Also der Präsident hat sich da ganz schnell dazu entschieden, dass das für seinen Verein in Ordnung ist. Das verbundet jetzt auch nicht weiter. Barca hat ja wirklich Bemühungen in den USA schon lange gestartet, versucht sich da zu positionieren auf dem Markt. Das ist jetzt nicht so neu. Steht da aber ein bisschen im Disput mit seinen Spielern, glaube ich. Das wird nicht ganz öffentlich, aber es ist ja nicht zu leugnen, dass diese Spieler eben auch in diesen Treffen teilgenommen haben, dass die Kapitäne der einzelnen Mannschaften ausgemacht hatten, um dort eben dann auch mit einem Streik zu drohen. Das darf man bei der ganzen Sache nicht vergessen. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass diese Tendenz sich momentan –ich glaube, das ist sogar sehr frisch, ich habe es heute früh gelesen –dass diese Tendenz sich ein bisschen als falsch herausstellt, weil der Verband offenbar entschieden hat, dass der Liga zu verbieten, dieses Auswärtsspiel in den USA durchzuführen.
Okay.
Es ist allerdings momentan noch ein reiner Medienbericht und ist unbestätigt. Es ist aber so, dass bei Kalena Koppe eine anonyme Quelle angekündigt, dass da ein Brief an Tebas, den Ligapräsidenten, geschickt werden soll, indem dieses Spiel in den USA vorerst mal verboten wird. Da darf man sich also noch auf ein bisschen Streit gefasst machen, schätze ich, zumal Tebas gestern Abend, gestern Nachmittag, ganz schön ausgeteilt hat gegen Kritiker, die das alles ein bisschen langsamer angegangen sehen wollen. Unter anderem auch gegen die FIFA und Infantino hat er da ein bisschen ausgeteilt. Der will das auf jeden Fall. Jetzt steht der Verband dagegen. Das muss man momentan noch abwarten, wie sich das genau entwickelt.
Ist das ähnlich wie in Deutschland, dass im Liga-Verband die Klubs sich selbst organisieren, dass wir davon ausgehen können, dass das schon eine von den Klubs mitgetragene Entscheidung war? Der spanische Verband ist dann aber ähnlich wie bei uns ein eigener Verband, der eben so Querverbindungen hat, aber so ähnlich wie hier mit DFB und DFL.
Das kann man glaube ich nicht eins eins exakt vergleichen. Aber wenn du nach den Vereinen fragst, ich glaube, dass die sich auch nicht ganz einig geworden sind, was sie denn da wollen. Du hast auf der einen Seite die Spieler, die eben sagen, das wird immer mehr und langsam wird es uns auch zu viel. Man muss da ja jetzt auch bedenken, so die sportliche Sicht, das ist eine Reise in die USA, sitzt du lange Zeit im Flugzeug, du kannst nicht trainieren, du verlierst auf der einen Seite Zeit, auf der anderen Seite hast du eine höhere Belastung durch dieses eine Spiel, das da ausgetragen wird. Und dann hast du auf der anderen Seite natürlich die Sicht der Funktionäre, der Führung, die sich da eben die schon besprochene Chance erhoffen, was Marketing angeht, was auch Einnahmen natürlich angeht. Das wird, glaube ich, auch innerhalb von den Vereinen sicherlich kontrovers diskutiert, wie mit dem Vorschlag umzugehen ist, weil er vor und Nachteile, sehr starke Vor- und Nachteile, glaube ich, mit sich bringt. Auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich auch nur ein Spiel von, was weiß ich, wie vielen Spielen, die in einem Jahr in Spanien ausgetragen werden, ob das jetzt der Supercup ist, bei dem es ja schon nach Marokko ging, ob es im Pokal ist, ob es in der Liga ist. Da sind ja unendlich viele Partien in diesen, nicht nur in der Saison, sondern auch in der nächsten Saison, die da sicherlich zur Debatte stehen werden. Das Thema ist ja nicht, auch wenn es der Verband jetzt verboten hat, tot, sondern die Bemühungen sind auf jeden Fall sehr stark.
Und wie reagieren die Fanszenen darauf? Ich frage das auch so ein bisschen vor dem Hintergrund. Wir steuern gerade auf einen Spieltag zu, also der fünfte Spieltag der ersten Liga, der siebte der zweiten Liga und der neunte Spieltag der dritten Liga. Da wird es jeweils in den ersten 20 Minuten keinen Support der organisierten Fans geben. Aus Kritik an DFB und DFL. Und ich würde jetzt mal behaupten, dieses Thema, wir verpflichten ein, wir verfrachten ein Pflichtspiel ins Ausland, ist noch ein viel größeres als die Themen, um die es jetzt gerade bei diesem Protest hier geht. Das heißt, hier haben wir schon eine solche konzertierte Aktion der Fans. Wie ist es da in Spanien?
In Deutschland würde ich das Ganze so ein bisschen als Schwelbrand bezeichnen. Also ich habe über diesen Konflikt zwischen DFB und den Fans kürzlich meine Bachelorarbeit geschrieben. Das ist ja tatsächlich so, dass das wirklich einen sehr langen historischen Hintergrund zum Teil auch hat, auf dem das Ganze fußt. Ich glaube, in Deutschland ist es oft so, dass Fans sich auf gar keinen Fall als Kunden betrachtet sehen wollen, sondern immer als Teilnehmer am Sport, die aktiv mitwirken, die mitgestalten und die durch ihre Art und Weise einen sehr wichtigen Teil des Fußballs ausmachen, was auch irgendwo stimmt, weil sie ja Teil des Wertschöpfungsprozesses sind, den die Bundesliga zum Beispiel hat. Wenn die Fans nicht mehr kommen, nicht mehr den Fernseher einschalten, dann werden die ganzen Rechte, die die Bundesliga oder die Clubs halten, ja auch unattraktiver für Sponsoren oder Unternehmen. In Spanien würde ich das ein bisschen in Frage stellen, ob es da genau die gleiche Sicht der Dinge gibt. Was dieses Mitwirken angeht, also gerade dadurch, dass Real oder Barca sich sowieso schon seit einer langen Zeit abgehoben haben von den Fans und sehr viel international machen, ist es schon ein bisschen mehr angekommen, dass man eher Kunde ist als Fan. Das ist jetzt natürlich auch einfach gesagt, es wird sicherlich auch Fans geben oder eine Menge Fans geben, die sich darüber beschweren. Letztendlich glaube ich, ist es aber schon so, dass in Spanien die Akzeptanz dafür ein bisschen höher ist.
Okay, und ich stelle fest, du hast dich für ein Tribüngespräch beworben, wer eine Bachelorarbeit zum Verhältnis zwischen DFB und Fan schreibt.
Können wir gerne machen, ja.
Ja, müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir dieses Thema greifen. Ben, das war mal wieder sehr interessant mit dir. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass du uns Einblick gegeben hast in die spanische Liga. Und danke euch auch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, fürs Zuschauen, zu hören. Der Rasenfunk bleibt werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Ihr könnt uns unterstützen auf rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Und ansonsten hinterlasst uns gerne Feedback zu dieser Folge unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Bis bald mal wieder, macht's gut!